en 1974 que la ville d'angoulême
présente son premier festival de la
bande dessinée quelques dessinateurs
français soutiennent cette initiative
malgré quelques imperfections et
quelques tâtonnements l'expérience est
concluante et elle sera poursuivie
l'année suivant française gauche l'année
dernière votre salon d'amendé ciné de
l'etec d'une expérience cette année pour
la deuxième édition qu'est ce que c'est
bon c'est d'abord la suite n'assure une
suite logique est un peu une explosion
puisqu'on va essayer de de faire
beaucoup chose en plus ces choses en
plus seront un chapiteau des conférences
des expositions et des animations
ce deuxième salon est également marquée
par la présence de dessinateurs
étrangers 16 nations donne ainsi
angoulême une image internationale 70
dessinateurs se mêle à la foule
et certains n'hésitent pas à dessiner
deux banques publiques l'audience
s'élargit le salon d'angoulême confirme
donc son utilité en 1976 pour sa
troisième édition le salon de la bande
dessinée prend une autre dimension
toute la ville d'angoulême est mobilisé
pour en assurer le succès le salon est
présent aux quatre coins de la ville
avec expositions conférences colloques
débats et film
les éditeurs eux sont réunis sous une
immense bulle de 700 m² qui deviendra le
symbole de la bd 81 scénariste et
dessinateur de 17 pays sont présents et
attire 30 mille personnes deux
événements marqueront le salon 77
d'abord la présence des rejets le père
de tintin qui préside ce quatrième salon
tintin a commencé leur a jamais cru un
seul instant que
aurait pu y avoir un jour un musée ces
choses là mais enfin ces chaussures se
trouve c'est très bien c'est une idée
remarquable pouvoir conserver tous
demain des témoignages dessinateur c'est
très bien et ensuite la création d'un
musée de la bande dessinée qui
s'installe comme il se doit à angoulême
après être devenu le témoin de son temps
la bd fiche donc ses souvenirs en 1978
le 5e salon pose une question la bande
dessinée est elle un fait culturel ou un
produit de consommation et en réponse le
jury couronne reiser et lui décerne une
prime à l'humour c'est pas du tout un
prix sérieux hein pourquoi le prendre
comme un bruit de ma
anne oscar lounge comme ça ça vous sont
connus tous sérieuses et c'est bon
enfant on sait la ville d'angoulême qui
a décidé de faire ça c'est une bonne
idée
en fait le salon se veut en prise
directe avec l'actualité et c'est pour
cela qu'il a récompensé un dessinateur à
l'humour parfois féroce